it's the start of another grandchild
tour season what makes the grandchester
tour special for you there are many
world's best players playing so it's not
every time I get a chance to
play such a strong tournament yeah I'm
very happy to play here in Romania it's
my first time actually to this country
and it's also my first year being
full-time player in
yeah it's of course a very strong event
and probably one of the best and I'm
looking forward to this evening I think
it's it's especially important this year
because it will also potentially decide
the Kansas qualification and I mean
besides that of course the branches tour
is also the biggest chess tour in the
world so it has its own individual
individual importance which is really
really big but uh but I'm actually extra
motivated this year well it's my only
major event here like this year yeah
obviously I'm
uh I would probably like to play more I
mean not right now and right now I would
probably skip but yeah okay life is hard
yeah I think granchester when it's first
merged it was the big you know sequence
of top events uh it remains a big
fixture
um and it's now well stronger than ever
everybody's participating yeah so the
grandchester I believe is one of a kind
event
um
since okay nowadays they're not many
close the top tournaments anyway being
organized but um especially in
connection with each other it's
extremely rare and I believe the last
series which was comparable was the
Grand Prix which was an official
tournament for the qualification and uh
even that is kind of gone so to me the
grandchester to stand alone yeah it's
not my first video in the Manchester
I've been playing it since since
Inception in 2015. so in a way it is
routine but it is still a very big
challenge playing every year against the
top players of the world and you know
finding new ways and all the usual stuff
but still keeping competitive at the
highest level is a huge challenge
obviously because okay in Grand Chester
I can play against the
best players in the world and it's good
well it's a combination of the best
chess players in the world and then
playing in the best tournaments in the
world the best organized story makes the
world also got the highest prices and
it's a season it's kind of like the NBA
people really look forward to watching
it and playing the event at the same
time for me the most important thing
about it is that it's the strongest tour
in the world and maybe in the history so
for it's very obvious for me that I have
to compete in it in my best so so I
could get the best results otherwise it
would be very challenging so that's very
important
[Music]